[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american comedy film
called shallow hal
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
a pre-teen named hal larson is by the
side of his father who is on his
deathbed with the last few moments mr
larson has left he talks about how much
he regrets marrying hal's mother he
tells his son to never settle for love
and always go for hotter women thanks
for scaring me for life dad the comment
leaves a huge impression on hal who
eventually grows up to become a shallow
man his obsession with women's bodies
and their looks keeps him from seeing
their true inner beauty currently he
works a 9-5 but the highlight of his day
is going to a club every night to get
with a different girl hal's partner in
crime is his equally shallow friend
mauricio he is a below average entitled
man who recently broke up with his
girlfriend because of her oddly shaped
toes as they talk about women hal
mentions that he has started dating his
hot neighbor jill but when he meets jill
later that night she blows him off hal
persists that they go out on a second
date but jill just doesn't feel
attracted to him to someone with an ego
as huge as hal's the comment hits home
at work the following day hal is excited
because he is about to get a
long-awaited promotion however his day
gets worse when someone else lands it
instead later hal walks into the
elevator and meets the popular life
coach tony robbins as they have a chat
the elevator suddenly stops and it takes
the building management a really long
time to get them out in the meantime
tony and hal get to know each other it
is evident by their comments that they
are polar opposites of each other tony
is in love with a single woman who he
respects and adores while hal tries to
get him to talk about how hot his woman
is tony also learns about hal's
non-existent love life and realizes it
is because of his shallowness as a life
coach he presents hal with simple advice
to date a person for their inner beauty
hal still doesn't take the advice
seriously so tony uses one of his
hypnosis techniques on him without hal
realizing it he begins to see average
looking women as hot and attractive
outside his office he encounters a woman
who he would consider a 10 out of 10 in
attractiveness they both catch a taxi at
the same time and decide to share the
ride throughout the ride hal
continuously flirts with the girl and
compliments her beauty when they are
about to separate hal asks for the
woman's number which surprises her the
girl introduces herself as katrina and
they share their numbers before hal
departs then he meets mauricio for a
drink as always and boasts about how he
got a hot girl's number a while later
mauricio returns from the washroom to a
strange sight hal is dancing with two
women who do not appear to be his usual
type then we find out that to hal the
below average women appear
conventionally attractive and skinny
tony's hypnosis has literally changed
the way he sees people a horrified
mauricio wants to take his friend away
from the girls who seem to have cast a
spell on him however hal doesn't want to
leave the pretty ladies on the dance
floor by themselves hal's neighbor jill
is also at the club she too notices him
dancing with the girls and starts
changing her view about him the next day
hal is driving down a busy road when his
eyes land on the most beautiful girl he
has ever seen her name is rosie and in
reality she is an obese woman who is the
opposite of hal's type but because of
his new vision hal likes her so much
that he follows her into a clothing
store he bluntly approaches rosie and
compliments her initially rosie thinks
he is trying to berate her since she is
not used to men walking up to her with
compliments she tries ignoring him but
his repeated progressions makes her
register that he is actually interested
in her they go out on a lunch date and
get to know more about each other rosie
works as a volunteer in a children's
hospital and is looking to re-up in the
peace corps she is definitely someone
with a pure heart who likes to help
people when she can this attribute of
hers impresses hal more than he
envisioned rosie orders half the things
on the menu which hal thinks is strange
because he is used to girls ordering
salad on first dates as they chat he
also discovers that rosie is the
daughter of the president of the company
where he works suddenly the chair that
rosie is seated on breaks making her
embarrassingly fall to the floor unaware
that it was caused by her weight hal
yells at the manager for using cheap
chairs the couple is about to separate
after the date when hal asks rosie for a
second one the proposal almost makes her
cry on their next date hal introduces
rosie to a surprised mauricio he is
confused as to how someone like hal
could date a girl like her when she is
not around he calls her a rhino and asks
his friend to come back to his senses
however hal is too smitten by rosie to
understand what mauricio is talking
about then we see rosie taking hell to
the hospital to meet the sick children
she volunteers to take care of they are
all very welcoming and sweet to hal
meeting the happy kids who have gone
through so much in their lives gives him
a different kind of satisfaction that he
has never experienced a little girl
named cadence catches his attention
because of his frank persona he
entertains the kids and makes them love
him which further impresses rosie she
comments that since hal is not afraid of
the children it will help boost their
confidence the statement confuses him
because who would be afraid of such
adorable children later that day rosie
walks hal to his apartment and bumps
into jill when jill finds out rosie as
hell's girlfriend she is amused and a
bit offended that he doesn't like her
anymore hal invites rosie to his
apartment and she awkwardly walks in
initially she is a bit nervous having
never been to a guy's place before but
how makes her feel at home with his
jokes things go downhill when rosie
mentions that she is not pretty she
believes the statement but hal insists
otherwise he showers her with
compliments that offend her because she
thinks he is obviously lying the night
ends when she abruptly leaves without
saying anything hal doesn't know what he
did wrong but he doesn't have to ponder
over it for long the very next morning
rosie comes home to apologize for
overreacting over a compliment in the
following montage we see them going out
on several dates getting to know each
other better and slowly falling in love
then one day the couple goes to rosie's
parents home for dinner since steve is
hal's boss he is more nervous than usual
things get awkward when hell comments
that rosie gets her figure from her
mother but other than that the dinner
goes pretty well when hal is alone with
steve steve calls him out for dating his
daughter to get ahead in his career hal
in turn calls him a horrible father for
making rosie feel like she's not good
enough to have a boyfriend who genuinely
likes her he blames steve for making
rosie feel ugly when she is the most
beautiful person inside and out the
comment makes his boss shut up later hal
and rosie are at his home when things
get steamy rosie is nervous because she
has always been insecure about her body
but how makes her feel like the
prettiest girl in the world they share a
beautiful night together the following
morning jill sees rosie walking down the
hallway and puts two and two together
something about hal falling for an
uglier girl hurts her ego and she starts
making advances at him she gives him a
bottle of wine as a gift and suggests
they play video games at night however
to her surprise hal turns her down the
next day hal impresses everyone at work
with his presentation amazed by his
creativity and personality steve
promotes him to a higher position than
his current boss one day hal and rosie
go on a double date with his friend walt
and his girlfriend tanya during their
date the couple bumps into ralph he is
rosie's ex-boyfriend and a member from
the peace corps rosie and he share a
small chat but ralph doesn't fail to
notice that she looks very happy in the
meantime mauricio is still not ready to
accept the fact that his friend can be
in love with someone obese he somehow
finds tony robbins and asks what he did
to his friend tony dodges the question
at first but when mauricio refuses to
leave him alone he admits to hypnotizing
hal into seeing women's inner beauty he
also reveals that to end the state of
hypnosis mauricio has only to say the
phrase shallow hal wants a gal to him
meanwhile rosie tells hal that her
ex-boyfriend ralph has invited her to
join him on a 14-month long mission in
kiribati for the peace corps although
she will be going for a good cause hal
gets upset because he thinks she wants
to get together with ralph suddenly
rosie's weight causes yet another chair
to break down hal helps her up before
having a word with the manager about
their cheap services while he is away
from the table he gets a call from
mauricio who says the trigger phrase but
doesn't get to explain the whole story
the phrase causes hal to return to his
normal self without him realizing it he
notices the real rosie sitting at his
table and looks at her in confusion
before he figures out what is going on
mauricio arrives in a rush and tells him
everything hal initially thinks his
friend is jealous and bluffing but then
he bumps into katrina the first girl who
he met after being hypnotized her face
confirms that he was in fact not in his
right mind whenever he was with rosie
hal panics and runs home without
informing his girlfriend he wants to go
back to the hypnotic state because he
loves rosie and doesn't want his
feelings to change when he sees her
actual face for the next few days hal
actively avoids meeting rosie while
simultaneously trying to get a hold of
tony so he can be hypnotized again a few
days later jill invites him to dinner at
a restaurant amidst all the things
happening right now hal is the least
interested in grabbing a bite with her
but she insists to a point where
refusing would be rude he eventually
gives in and the two go out for dinner
jill takes the opportunity to tell him
she has noticed the subtle changes in
him and is impressed she is clearly
interested in dating him but hal has
only one person on his mind jill's
advances make him realize that he is in
love with rosie coincidentally rosie and
her family arrive at the same restaurant
at the same time she sees her boyfriend
who has been ignoring her for the past
week holding hands with another girl
rosie automatically assumes they are
dating and is left heartbroken hal walks
right past her but doesn't recognize her
which makes her feel worse than she
already did but in reality he is walking
to a pay phone to call her he does so
and tries to reassure her of his
feelings however rosie breaks up with
him before ending the call a few days
pass that are the hardest days for both
rosie and hal hal finds out from her
father that her ex-boyfriend ralph wants
to be in a relationship with rosie again
hal goes to the hospital where she works
to look for her but instead bumps into
cadence he had seen the little girl with
a perfect face when he came previously
but now with the filter of hypnosis gone
he sees the little girl has severe burns
all over her face still her confidence
and will to live life inspires him to
his core her personality is enough for
how to change his perception of physical
beauty hal also discovers that mauricio
has an inoperable vestigial tale because
of which he breaks up with women before
they get into the second phase of the
relationship being a good friend hal
convinces mauricio to accept his
abnormality i remember that scene
traumatizing me when i was a child then
hal heads to the peace corps recruiting
office where he doesn't find rosie but
meets ralph ralph informs him that
rosie's parents are throwing her a
farewell party before she leaves for the
peace corps mission hal ralph and
mauricio crash the party where hal
apologizes to rosie although she is mad
at him she loves him too much to not
forgive him the pair reconcile as the
crowd cheers hal tries to pick his
girlfriend up but when he is not
successful rosie does the favor for him
in the last scene mauricio also finds a
girl who is interested in him despite
his condition they walk into the sunset
as he wags his tail
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching